Caitlin Collins is that you're talking I
believe so that's she's an interesting
person and I don't want to I don't want
to add homonym on that girl too much
because but I just noticed I'm not I'm
not at homing her I'm just saying it was
very yeah I'm about to so I'm just
saying beforehand I don't want to but
I'm going to I like her but I mean I
like that what she's doing I'm glad
she's out there but like her smile she's
got like I don't know if she got work
done on her face but the sides of her
mouth are like up in a smile but
everything about her face shows misery
doesn't smile behind the eyes yeah
there's lots of people like that in
media yeah um it's a sort of I I don't
want to psychoanalyze or step outside by
remix Telltale sign a psychopathy yeah I
was I was just gonna say that I'm not
going to speak to her condition
specifically but that that is something
you'll notice there's exactly and that's
why it makes sense that there's so many
people in the media who have that kind
of face that and that is Hillary
Clinton's face right I mean she's very
much got that phony smile